there are friends who have very well
meaning but who nevertheless have a
habit of responding in unfortunate ways
when we reveal a trouble to them they
try with considerable vigor to cheer us
up we may appreciate their underlying
good nature while nevertheless
profoundly resenting their particular
technique for what we may want from them
above all is not a swift in joinder that
our problems are in fact despite
appearances easily solvable but rather a
shared moment of sadness and mournful
sympathy there are times when we can't
believe in quick answers but we want
company nevertheless we want to give way
to a low-level muted sadness and a joint
acceptance that life is inherently
difficult sadness isn't always a
disorder that needs to be cured and yet
the dominant tone of many friendships
continues to be cheerful or it's more
brittle cousin cheery a good mood that
tolerates no other this falsely presumes
that the best way to please others must
always be to impose a vibrant frame of
mind when in fact admission of despair
is a key tool in the process of
friendship properly reimagined in a
discussion of parenting styles the
psychoanalyst Donald Winnicott once
identified a particularly problematic
kind of child care er the person who
wants to jolly babies and small children
along always picking them up with
exaggerated cheer bouncing them up and
down and pulling wide funny faces
perhaps shouting peekaboo repeatedly
this criticism might feel disconcerting
what could be so wrong with wanting to
keep a child
jolly yet Winnicott was worried by what
effect this would have on a child the
way it was subtly not giving the child
any chance to acknowledge its own
sadness or more broadly its own feelings
that Julia doesn't give the child an
opportunity to set the tone he or she
just wants to impose a mood which may
have no basis in the child's reality
that Julia doesn't only want the child
to be happy
more alarmingly it can't tolerate the
idea that it might be sad
so unexplored and potentially
overwhelming are their own feelings of
unresolved disappointment and grief
childhood is necessarily full of sadness
as adulthood must be to insisted
Winnicott which means we must
perpetually be granted the possibility
of periods of mourning for a broken toy
the gray sky on a Sunday afternoon or
perhaps the lingering sadness we can see
in our parents eyes the friend no less
than the carer needs to remember how
much of life deserves to have solemn and
mournful moments and of how much loyalty
we will always be ready to offer those
who don't feel aggressively compelled to
deny our melancholy
you